okay so Black Adam has a big ending
major Cameo and lots of things that set
up the future of the DC EU throughout
this video we're going to be going
through the plot Easter eggs explaining
the characters and also our thoughts on
the film I just want to get straight
into it and in case you missed the
channel name there will be heavy
spoilers from here on out if you enjoy
the video please Rock Bottom that thumbs
up button and make sure you subscribe
you [ __ ] jabroni without the way
thanks for clicking this thank you very
much now let's get into Black Adam
are not a gift
but a curse okay so if you're just
coming out of the film then the first
thing you probably want to see us talk
about is the Return of Superman Henry
Cavill has been shrouding as soups and
after years of wondering whether he's in
the role or not it seems like he's back
he's [ __ ] back
now let's talk about the scene first
before we go over what it means the film
ends with Black Adam being told that
he's unable to leave his kingdom in
kandak in the DC Universe this is the
birthplace of Black Adam and the movie
recaptures its architecture perfectly
even down to the statues we learned that
teth Adams started off as a slave there
and that he mined minerals for the evil
King Acton this is a villain from the
comics who was changed up for the film
and in the source material he's more
along the lines of metamorpho yeah
though teth Adams Beginnings tie [ __ ]
with sir back and initially he's a slave
who's forced to mine minerals that will
help make his crown this is known as
eternium which I thought was a mobile
game anyway it's reveal that Adam's son
was originally granted Powers by the
Wizards that too would give Billy bats
in his thousands of years later when
Adam's wife was killed his son
transferred his abilities into his
father but sadly the king's assassins
were waiting and they killed him just
after this we learned that teth Adam can
I just call him Black Adam right yeah
you learn that Black Adam actually kill
the Council of wizards and that's why
Shazam just has the one in it similar to
Billy Adam's powers are activated and
deactivated by saying the word Shazam in
the Injustice comic book he does this at
one point and it turns him into a
withered old man which I was hoping
they'd do in the movie sadly they don't
and when he's depowered he just appears
like 12 stone instead of the rock hey
now the guy is pretty built to be fair
even for the quote-unquote skinny
version now in the film Adam destroyed
most of the kingdom and this happened
when he was raging against the Ancient
King that's why he wrestles back and
forth over being a hero as he knows deep
down that he has this darker side to him
nor do I Surrender
here we go
I kneel before no one now the movie ends
with him destroying kandex throne and
choosing to be its protector instead of
its leader this is similar to the comics
and in those he was originally brought
in as a Shazam villain however after the
turn of the Millennium he was given more
overall as an anti-hero who refused to
let the rest of the world walk all over
kandak anyway Wallace ends in a
holographic drone that forbids him from
leaving and she says that this is now
his prison this is when Adam says no one
on this planet can stop him from leaving
and while it taunt him by saying that
she can call in a favor she has several
people she can send in who aren't from
this planet and this sets up the
prodigal son's return the rock destroys
the Drone and this is when Henry Cavill
appears as Superman we can see him
looking slightly more geared towards his
classic comic book look as well as the
Christopher Eve Incarnation that was a
staple of most of our childhoods his
suit is brightened up with a yellow
especially standing out in the ass and
he now has a curl in his hair the John
Williams score is also accompanying him
instead of the Hans Zimmer one and oh no
no not again not again
anyway the two sharing the screen
together is a big thing and apparently
getting Cavill back was so down to the
wire that this scene wasn't actually
shot up until September there's lots of
foreshadowing to their eventual Showdown
with Adam even lighting up a poster of
Superman after waking up in iman's room
now this scene very much Echoes the
ending a Man of Steel with the boot now
being on the other foot in that Khalil
smashed a drone like it was the like
button and told the government that they
would never control him even though he
was there to help black Adam's
motivations could really go either way
and soups rightly says that he's making
the world very nervous this is similar
to soups himself with a government being
and share over whether to trust the hero
or not now in the case of Superman it
was more straightforward with him
clearly being a good guy Black Adam on
the other hand is a completely different
entity and tying back to Injustice
something similar happened in the comics
in that Superman decided to become an
oppressive dictator after the death of
Lois and his unborn child at the hands
of the Joker he and his regime traveled
to kandak to stop Black Adam after
missiles at the location from outside
evil forces Black Adam was Furious
they'd been attacked and he wanted to
strike back and make the world paper
what they'd done this pit the two
against each other and we got the
aforementioned scene Black Adam at one
point remarks at Superman's regime is
based on his rule of kandak though I
don't think we'll see Adam is a dictator
in the movies instead I think they could
bring in the missile plot line with it
potentially being fired from the US now
this could be the classic versus type
movie where it's revealed that there's a
True Villain behind it all who's
manipulating everything this would
follow the classic versus formula and
it's something we've seen in Batman v
Superman and Godzilla vs Kong however
with Batman v Superman already being
pretty close I'm not sure they'd do that
the reason I'm bringing it up though is
because Dwayne Johnson recently
confirmed with Cinema Blend that he
absolutely plans to bring Black Adam vs
Superman to the screen when problem if
it would happen he said absolutely
that's the whole point of this man bit
of crap impersonation there but
regarding fighting Superman on the big
green Johnson then said I've been
waiting for someone to step up and
address fans and say hey we hear you so
finally after many months turned into
many airs we ended up what we ended up
at and the whole goal and intention now
is to this new era new time now let's
build out a Superman fighting him could
be the plot of the next Blackout movie
but first we have confirmation that Man
of Steel 2 is now in development the
original was first released all the way
back in 2013 and after numerous
appearances alongside other characters
I'm glad we're finally getting a solo
Superman movie Warner Brothers announced
this earlier in the week and they
clearly did it to Hype up Black Adam the
best way to Market a movie is to Hype up
the next one so it feels must see and
you can totally see why they made a
crystal clear that the Man of Steel will
be back to Man of Steel the scene again
anyway this could potentially be the
Black Adam vs movie itself and Henry
Cavill versus The Rock would be a
massive selling point to get people in
seats this video is sponsored by man
escaped the new 4.0 package has made a
massive difference to my grooming
routine so I thought I'd team up with
them to bring you this amazing New Deal
whether you're brand new to this
universe like the rock or well-equipped
at trimming your Stones this new kit can
help align your entire hygiene routine
in one Fell Swoop inside the new Tempo
package is everything you love about the
performance one and some new shower
goodies that can elevate your game to
platinum firstly we have the lawnmower
4.0 body trimmer and the weed whacker
nose and ear hair trimmer both come with
Advanced Skin safe technology that can
make you feel like Mr Man of Steel your
girl got them loads of times absolutely
love them they always work a tree and
massively help me up my game you can
also now completely upgrade your shower
routine with the Ultra Premium body wash
and Ultra Premium two in one shampoo and
conditioner your hair and skin will feel
strong and more hydrated than Aquaman
there's also the aluminum Free Ultra
Premium deodorant and also the crop
preserver ball deodorant as always you
get the crop Revival ball toner spray
and this makes sure your Adam's smashes
stay smelling great until this manscape
divorce are thrown in two free gifts
this includes the man's gay boxers and
also the shed travel bag that I've
carried with me wherever I go anytime I
go away this has got the whole kit in it
so go to manscape.com and get 20 off and
free shipping with the code heavy
spoilers that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com when you enter
the code heavy spoilers at checkout
manscape help you clear out the leaves
this fresh ball fall and it's time for
your tree trunk to shine my haircut game
isn't on point right now looking like
Cliff Richards but huge thank you to
manscape for making sure everything else
is locked down thanks a black element
Superman have brought off against each
other several times in the comics before
CBR have done a big list on this if you
want to check them all out I thought I'd
keep things simple on the video and just
focus on the main one that I think
they'll adapt this happens in Action
Comics 831 and it involves the pair
duking it out of metropolis we're
discovering that Alexa Luther is pulling
their strings and that he'd hide Adam to
bring psycho pirate in turns out that
Luther had also hired psycho pirate 2
but he'd gone Rogue and started using
his powers to trick people into ending
their own lives Superman had been
investigating this and this is what
leads to the main conflict Superman
thinks that Adam is working with pirate
and the pair end up duking it out
against each other I think they might
end up bringing in the missile plot we
talked about before and then Adam would
travel out the US in order to
investigate things you might believe
sups is involved with it which would
make sense as we see he's now working
alongside Waller in this scene I have no
idea why he's with her as she's pretty
bad but it's something they could
explore in an upcoming film there's also
the possibility that he himself is
keeping an eye on Adam and this is why
he wants to have an intriguing word
intriguing it is instead of working with
wallet he could be there to Simply see
how he reacts to her and then try and
broke a piece without him to avoid a
planetary War there is some potential
subtext to the scene with him talking
about how nervous Adam is making the
plan planet and potentially he is his
own agent for the Justice League that
just wants to come in now he knows he's
not working with task force x The
Suicide Squad is someone that the
Justice League would steer clear of so
yeah that's just another way that I
interpreted the scene I was on the team
I didn't burn a passport you don't need
passports
to the Justice Society
Black Adam we're here to negotiate your
peaceful surrender now as for the movie
itself there are some big characters in
it Perseus of Arc who like Adam was
introduced as a Shazam villain in the
comics we've seen several people take up
the role with Timothy cons and Ishmael
Gregor in the movie it's a ladder with
us learning that he's the descendant of
Acton somebody Shazam his powers come to
fruition when he says his name so you
very much have a mirror in that and he
rules the intergang who are basically
the group in name only and the comics
they possess technology from the new
gods of Apocalypse well here they're
basically just mercenaries that rule
over kandak they're predominantly
Superman foes in the source material
that operate out of metropolis however
they have worked out of Gotham too and
they became involved in the war between
penguin and Tobias whale also side note
did anyone keep thinking it's the rock
when when the sun kept throwing it up
well I thought that and then I also
wondered if it was a rock rock pun
anyway moving on we're also introduced
to the JSA which contains the members
Hawk man Cyclone Dr Fate and Adam
Smasher and the latter actually has a
phone call with the original Adam
Smasher AKA Al Rothstein he's played by
the Fonz AKA Henry Winkler who gets an a
for effort now that you blood can
now the new blood can actually alter his
molecules to change his size and
strength our version debuted in 1996
using the name nucleon but now he's
taken over the mantle he called him by
Wally to stop Black Adam and this could
also explain why she goes further up the
chain and ends up calling in Superman
Doctor Fate also has visions that tell
of hawkman's death but in the end he
chooses to sacrifice himself in order to
save his friend he's such a cool
character that constantly uses magic and
his abilities were ripped right out of
the comics and Injustice fighting game
he's one of the oldest comic book
characters of all time and fate was
introduced all the way back in 1940 in
the book more fun Comics 55. Kent Nelson
worked as an archaeologist and during an
expedition he discovered the tomb of
Naboo which instilled in him incredible
abilities as we see in the film he and
his helmet have a special Bond James
Bond and he's considered a sorcerer
that's a very strange Doctor Who can fly
teleport travel through Dimensions turn
invisible and so on and so forth similar
to Dr Fate orc man was also introduced
in the 1940s during Flash comics issue
1. there's been several origin stories
for the character and like fate he's
been retconned many times over the
decades originally he took the name
Carter Hall and he was also an
archaeologist who was revealed to be The
Reincarnation of the ancient priest kuhu
ancient priest goof I don't know why I
said like that now in the 1970s they
updated hawkman's origin story and made
him cut a hall who was an alien cop that
traveled to Earth and then gained the
name Carter Hall Hawk Girl sadly doesn't
appear in the movie but I'll be going
forward we can get an appearance by here
the last character that spot of the JSA
is Cyclone who is the newest member in
terms of comic continuity she showed up
in 2007 and came forward as Red
Tornado's granddaughter as a teen she
was kidnapped and injected with
nanobites which then gave her the power
to control air particles in the wind
there's also Adriana and her son who
someone act as a mirror of the wife in
child that Adam lost thousands of years
ago you also get a cameo from Hawk chord
who you'll likely know from The Suicide
Squad and Peacemaker this all ties in
with the task force x base that Adam
ends up going to after the powering
himself either way they end up all
working together to take down sabak
which leads to Adam ripping him apart
though Adam was wanted by Walla the
goody does in the end somewhat helps to
ride his record but that doesn't mean
she's gonna let him get a free pass over
the world he chooses not to be a king
after we get clear imagery from the
comics and instead he's gonna become
kandak's Champion that closes off the
movie and the main points in it and I
hope you enjoy the extra bits of info
and my thoughts on where I think things
will be going the world needed a hero
[Applause]
instead it got me so the main question
is did the hierarchy of power in the DC
Universe finally change well I think it
came pretty close and though the movie
isn't perfect it's still a fun ride that
I enjoyed you can probably watch the
trailer and work out the entire plot
because it didn't really reinvent the
wheel however what elevates this movie
is its cast action themes and the story
of an anti-hero The Rock really brought
it and this guy makes a big impression
on screen and you can tell he's been
waiting a while to do it if you can't
believe it he was cast back in 2007 and
though I do feel like elements of the
movie feel slightly dated because they
were clearly working on it for a long
time they ended up telling a story that
might be by the numbers but it also
works really well now due to the movie
being in production for so long there
are some things here that clearly take
from other superhero movies there's nods
to the X-Men Adam smash's mask appears
similar to Deadpool's and obviously he
has them and stuff too then you got Dr
Fate who though created before strange
has moved moves here that are clearly
inspired by how he is in Infinity War
saying that though fate is one of the
standouts in the film I love what they
did with him it's even possible that
they knew these Marvel comparisons would
be made which is why they removed that
shot from the trailer with the two jets
that was similar to Iron Man the music
changes to more modern songs also made
some action scenes jarring and honestly
with how good the score was I was
surprised that they leaned into the
songs that they ended up choosing
however these are just really nitpicks
and things that don't really damage the
movie that much out if at all now I have
talked about on Twitter a couple of
times and I think that Dwayne Johnson is
genuinely putting his heart and soul
into this role both on and off the
camera even my nana texted me the other
day asking about him and if he's Nana
approved then he's Kevin spoilers
approved I think he's massive in stature
and is the kind of person that should be
in a row like this due to the almost
gladiatorial level that he brings to it
though initially marketed as something
that could probably stand on its own
this gives me hope that DC now have a
plan due to the tie-ins with Amanda
tolerant soups weirdly it doesn't look
like anything against Shazam is on the
horizon though rocker said they'll
obviously face up at some point I don't
know what the tone of that will be but
we'll we'll see either way I think this
was a solid first entry even if it was
by the Numbers though it goes through
the motions it's the effects and Cass
are elevated up and the reveals about
the Sun and just stuff like that that
keeps it all engaging so overall in the
end 7.5 out of 10. now I'm sure most of
you have seen the Rotten Tomatoes score
and I actually wonder if this might work
in its favor it has me really wanting to
shout from the rooftops that this movie
is good I think a lot of people will do
the same and how to promote it more I
definitely think that people should go
see it it's a fun popcorn ride and call
me shillium shill spear cause it's
something I want to see do well I didn't
even mention the side characters with
Adriana her brother and son and they all
provided a lot of heart and comic relief
to the movie it's fun there's lots of
things going on bit bit simplistic but
yeah you'll have it you'll have a good
ride go to the movies obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts on it and what you
want to see next time we are running in
competition right now giving away three
copies of top gun Maverick on the 15th
of November and all you have to do to be
on with a chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on drop a comment below
with your thoughts on the film you pick
the comments at random on the 15th and
the winners of the last one on screen
right now so that's you then message me
on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch make sure you
check out one of our breakdowns on
screen now which will be linked to one
of the boxes thanks for sticking through
the video really nice having you sit
until the end uh got nothing else to say
so I'll see you in the next one take
care peace